hallo leute ich es wieder mal waren und
willkommen zur wissenschaftlichen
analyse meines gesicht und jetzt wollen
wir doch mal schauen
willst du meine haut steht also richtig
an
mein gott ist mein fingernagel
schmunzelte ich schwöre ich sehe das
nicht mal mit meinem auge um grad leute
kämen wuseln er war so kraft ok jetzt
gucken wir uns meine haut an was habe
ich denn so schöne haut das nickel ihk
stop ist mit gerade mal 30 euro gekostet
warum habe ich so viele volkswirte und
mein gott es macht spaß
also man sieht auf jeden fall diese
ganzen sachen artikels hoch schippchen
ich glaube ich habe eine sehr sehr viel
tote haut drauf liegt weil ich mich
nicht so die augenbrauen
ich will ja auch dickere augenbrauen
kriegen ich sehe zu lösen
befragt
jetzt sehen wir meine augenbrauen das
ist auf jeden fall wichtig zu sehen dass
ich viele haare sind gar nicht so viele
habe
vor allem will ich so oben mehr
augenbrauen kriegen so kommen wir da
kommen
das ist das soll alles besser werden und
ich bin ganz schön froh durchpeitschen
augenringe mir keine mitesser
ich habe auch gar nicht viele mit es
deswegen das wird so habe jetzt so jetzt
gar nicht auf der nase
du musst du schauen das ist ein
typischer mit sv muss man so dr simple
puppendoktor pimpl puppe tat da das
einfach besser als letztes noch meine
kopfhaut auf der reise nach barnettas
kopfhaut aber ich würde sagen dass der
teil weg gefunden habe nicht
stattgefunden da seine schuppel ich weiß
ihr wollte so etwas wahrscheinlich
niemals sehen aber worldwide channel
aber ich würde sagen eine komplette gar
nicht so ungesund auch wenn ich mir
machen dieses kombiniert zu übergeben
können jetzt schauen
okay wir haben also mit kaffee versagen
meine hausbank
das war nicht schön aus ich würde sagen
das ist etwas dagegen zu tun
also auf ins badezimmer
[Musik]
weiter geht es mit unserem 80 euro ein
buch scherben wo ich bin ist das zeug
machen weil ich glaube es nicht so
geeignet dafür ist einfach so es fühlt
sich allerdings bringen würde
[Musik]
streichen sie den vibrierenden gemacht
ja ich bin glaube ich wenn ich danach
nicht gebildet haben so hat er mir eine
werbung für die wm
er hat es brennt auf jeden fall ist okay
nächstes produkt jetzt kommt nämlich
unsere 80 euro maske auf dem eriesee und
der rest in pieces make my day an chips
klinikums klar wolf phase 1 europa sei
nicht ganz anders aus dem supersommer 50
das brennt seiner mich im klerus ihr
haupt oder bestimmt mein gesicht hatte
höchste da so jetzt kommen wir zur
schritt 2 also gut zwei minuten
einwirken lassen
das setzt den anti aging verbieten wenn
ich nicht so schnell und genau das ist
es das kostet 80 euro
das sind nicht nur die zwei sondern 30
tage 30 x 480 euro knapp aber dieses
bürsten ding macht man einmal am abend
und das zeug muss man morgens
ja man kann damit die pflege weiterhin
voll ausgenutzt das super denn ist
erstmal weiter mit den drei euro pro die
zukunft und debatten vor 5 6
okay wir haben uns hier und da müssen
wir diese machte da rein machen
[Musik]
das denkt hängt an mich zu passieren was
passiert mich echt sch egal was passiert
das war's woher bekomme ich dann ist
noch mehr masten nur ein bekommt es ist
voll geil
[Musik]
also ich fühle mich jetzt nicht so wie
fresh gesagt das ganze zeug bin ich
nicht glaube es könnte gut sein dass
weiß auch paypal eine serie für mich ein
bisschen überfordert so nach dieser
aufregenden gesichtsbehandlung brauche
ich erstmal etwas beruhigen ist 140 euro
krise
140 euro und kopfschmerzen da kriegt man
doch keine sorgenfalten cremig euro
creme welt auf ihr gesicht viel zu viel
hab ich wünsche mir echt weiter und sie
ist auch extrem robuster feldbach hier s
bahn liegt mir heute abend noch mal
diese komische brille ausprobieren und
dieses wimpern und augenbrauen see und
drauf machen und dann gucken wir zum
haus am mikroskop an was meine frau dann
heute abend so sagt wie die so drauf ist
ja es ist nicht der nächste tag sondern
ungefähr vier wochen später ich weiß
nicht wohin die zeit verflogen erst ich
dachte immer ich dresden nächsten tag am
nächsten tag am nächsten tag und dann
war es plötzlich vier wochen aber ich
war sehr fleißig mit meiner beauty
pflege ihr habt auch in einem
adventskalender unboxing gesehen dass
ich neue produkte gefunden habe die mir
dabei helfen das schönste schwan im
teich zu werden und meine haare wurde
derzeit noch mal gefärbt also sehen
jetzt auch ein bisschen frischer aus und
ich habe mittlerweile die dritte schiene
in den zähnen ich glaube nicht dass man
jetzt mittlerweile noch hört nur wenn
ich mich wirklich drauf kommen sind ja
nur weil ich mich wirklich konzentriert
dann kriegen das nicht hin
ich denke immer noch also zum drehen
nämlich die meisten voraus weil sie
glänzen einfach im alltag wenn ich leute
gefragt aber hat niemand gecheckt das
ist eine spannende frage
das hat irgendwann über voll stolz
darauf gespart wird so gar nicht gemerkt
ich muss sagen dass wenn man eine neue
stelle einsetzt dass es wirklich dolby
die ersten zwei tage die ersten stunden
am meisten weil der druck ist dann halt
ein intensives intensivsten und dann
fliegt der schmerz langsam also gestern
hatte ich zum tag haben wir die
vorderzähne voll weh getan hat auch die
suche ich empfindlich wären aber sonst
geht es eigentlich sonst bin ich sehr
zufrieden und ich uns schon ein shampoo
gefunden mit dem ich sehr zufrieden bin
ich bin aber zu die rennen gegangen und
habe gesagt ich wollte einfach das
teuerste was es hier gibt und das war
john frieda repair in die box shampoo
und conditioner und damit bin ich sehr
zufrieden
150 euro konnte ich mal den ich am
anfang benutzt habe wir hatten fällt mir
halt überhaupt nicht und war ein ganz
tolles zeichen für mich immer nur teuer
ist am besten mehr durch das kinder und
jetzt kommen wir zum letzten mal wirkt
was wir ausprobieren möchten bevor wir
nochmal einen mikroskop festmachen
die brille ich habe ein bisschen angst
vor dieser stelle muss ich ehrlich war
ich habe einfach angst vor dingen die
leuchtenden mein gesicht rein gedrückt
werden sollen kurse ehrlich sagen ich
bin ja auch so migränepatienten deswegen
was ich eigentlich zufällig zu sehen
weil das manchmal trägern kann falls sie
mich noch vor zwei sekunden attraktiv an
die wand gedrückt obwohl vor
okay ich bin ich meine augen aufmachen
das war frauenheld und ich bin voll
geblendet was sieht man das rot
[Musik]
oder sollte man sein gehirn extrem was
macht es jetzt aber wie soll denn jetzt
licht meine falten weg machen und ich
soll das täglich anwenden und haben
wollten verändert sich die lichtfarbe
oder wenn ich gerade produkt blinkt mal
waren und mit einer neuen folge wie
erstelle ich mein augenlicht vielleicht
sammle das gerät gerade meine gedanken
und schickt es dann so an das
kontrollzentrum das von ganz vielen
frauen mit falten von frauen
ich kann die zeit nutzen und natürlich
darüber erzählen meine augen brauchen
wir euch ein bisschen voller geworden
sind von dem zeug die vermutung des
tages dieses ding bringt nichts drei
minuten später das würde ich mal
getragen
ich würde das gerät jetzt spontan so
nicht empfehlen natürlich kann ich erst
was dazu sagen wenn ich jetzt ein paar
monate verwendet habe also in teilnehmer
3 es war aber auch ein bisschen gruselig
musiker an to the next und nun ist es
zeit wieder in das mikroskop zu schauen
denn ich habe jetzt vier wochen bleiben
mich wirklich um meines kind gekümmert
ich habe meinen sie sich gebürstet
ordentlich eingecremt wie lange grämen
muss ich wirklich sagen
euro die ist schon gut die fühlt sich
sehr gut an und ich habe ein bisschen
das gefühl dass meine roten tatsächlich
in dem sich weniger geworden sind
auch wenn es in der kamera immer so
aussehen als ob ich drei tage nicht
geschlafen hätte also vor vier wochen
sein gesicht auch noch wie die sahara
ich habe das gefühl mittlerweile ist sie
irgendwie weicher ich habe eine zarte
haut
aber auch der titel es ist mir
aufgefallen es machte spaß ich liebe
dich angemalt mit der man hier an mutig
hermann unterschied sieht man jetzt da
sind wieder die altbekannten puzzle mit
es am kinn gibt es immer noch eine sache
will ich auf jeden fall kontrollieren
und zwar habe ich das gefühl dass von
diesen augenbrauen sehr um meine augen
braucht ein bisschen also da wachsen die
haare
seit ein paar tagen und ich dachte
vielleicht sieht man sie unter dem
mikroskop
nein ich muss genau den punkt treffen so
ich habe es mir nicht eingebildet da
sieht man überall kleine baby habe diese
zwischen den großen hahn wachsen vor
allem hier so und nach vier wochen sieht
man wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht so
einen großen unterschied
ich habe schon das gefühl dass diese
ganzen kleinen haare da zwischen den
großen hahn neu sind mit der sonne
jeder kennt sie mit mars auf team
angekommen das war ja letztes mal war
das ja sahara ist das noch so krasse
harrer das letzte mal
das ist ein ganz ein ganz klassischer
werden in der fachsprache pickel zieht
aber auch im winter hat für mich ja
nicht meine haare das möchte ich noch
mal schauen
das ist ja eine super gesunde kopfhaut
und immer weniger
es ist so verrückt im wiesn naturdoku
ist eine richtige epische kamerafahrt
wir sehen in den tiefen deswegen welt
wirklich wenn ihr langeweile habt
besorgt euch so ein mikroskop das kostet
30 euro und schaue einfach dinge wenn
youtube länder den schwaben nämlich ganz
gut was halte ich mir da in mainz
minister ist auch bisschen verstaubt
[Musik]
folglich muss das mit pinsel holen eines
muss ich auch machen also so sieht man
haut aus ohne make up schicht make-up
draufmachen festhaltend ist eklig
menschen sind täglich jetzt haben wir
eine produkte getestet und natürlich
kann ich erst in ein paar wochen sagen
ob ich mit den produkten auch zufrieden
bin und ob sie was gebracht haben
ich kann aber jetzt schon mal sagen dass
ich sehr froh bin den zahn schiene
angefangen habt zu benutzen weil sich
das echt gut anfühlt zu müssen dass bald
diese vorderen zähne dich schön gerade
sind und danke nochmal an sun shines mal
dass sie mich da auch unterstützen den
rabattcode mal wandel findet ihr auch
nochmal unten in der infobox alle
anderen produkte findet ihr auch unten
verlinkt gibt's im video fitna in dem
hof hat es euch gefallen werden wenn ihr
wollt dass sich noch mehr tolle sachen
ausprobiere und schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
tipps tricks
was ihr so zu mittag gegessen habt bis
dann
[Musik]